if it's all going to come crashing down
go buy some chickens
man because uh
the people who are able to sustain
themselves more than others are going to
be better off if this is the trend that
continues I do think there's an
alternative that's why I said we need to
make America great again and I don't
know if I'm saying it in the exact same
way that all the Trump supporters saying
about but but I imagine probably when
Jack was up it brings up Pizza Hut when
he was a kid and there's a salad bar and
if you read a book in school they gave
you a free donut and you got a free I
don't know there's a bunch of all I
remember was that's all I remember
because I remember I get there was a
Pizza next to a Dunkin Donuts so I'd get
the free pizza and then we were leaving
go get a free donut there was other
stuff on it like something that was like
drug addiction like they give you the
cheese and the high fructose corn syrup
and the sauce with sugar and you're done
good old days
bro I doubt back then they had all that
stuff it was like after 92 it was when
the high fructose started coming in but
we were living in a haze of ignorance at
that time